das interessiert mich auch überhaupt
nicht so frauen
germany's next topmodel hey was geht ab
willkommen zu einem neuen video uns war
ich denke der eine oder andere hat am
titel schon gelesen es geht heute um das
nervige an einer beziehung was hier mal
vorweg sagen was denn jetzt bitte nicht
ich finde eine beziehungs oder so also
es gibt auf jeden fall vorwiegend
positive dinge aber es gibt halt auf 100
ein oder andere negative darum geht es
heute ich habe mir ein bisschen
unterstützung geholt von moritz gab es
vielleicht kennt ihr der ein oder andere
von euch
es gibt ein paar von dem video auf einem
kanal den anderen findet ihr auf seinem
kanal alles in der video beschreibung am
ende verlinkt und gewalt hass auf jeden
fall nach oben da und jetzt viel spaß
mit dem video
ich würde sagen logischerweise mit punkt
eins an wie immer natürlich und zwar ist
das so wenn man so zum beispiel jetzt
bei sich war und man hat zu den ganzen
artikel so man ist schon so ein bisschen
müde und dann kommt immer noch diese
eine sache die hand übers nervt und zwar
musste man immer auf deine freundin nach
hause bringe dem fahrrad oder so
meistens halten oder du musst sie
generell nach hause bringen das ist also
die aufgabe des jungen ich meine ist
natürlich auch voll normal und okay aber
es kann ab und zu richtig auf den sack
in wenn es draußen noch kalt ist es
windig zumindest im winter dann redet
jetzt auch noch oder so und da denkt man
sich so eigentlich könnte jetzt auch
gerne hier bei mir bleiben kann man aber
nicht bringen
der erste punkt der ziemlich nervige
neuer beziehungen sein kann ist das wenn
man weggehen will immer haben wir so
eine stunde mehr einkalkulieren muss
weil die freundin sich also lange fertig
macht und dann mal wieder nichts zum
anziehen findet ein fragt ob sie diese
schuhe oder diese schuhe anziehen soll
sie aber dann doch die dritten anzieht
dann schauen muss wie das wetter wird ob
sie sich ihre haare über klettern muss
oder doch irgendwie mit lockigen haaren
rausgeht und nach einer bis anderthalb
stunden sie dann fertig und man kann
endlich losgehen da sie schon ziemlich
nervenzerreißende und nervig das nächste
ist auch sehr sehr wichtig und zwar
sollte man immer darauf achten sonst hat
man bestimmt direkt verpackt was heißt
direkt aber so wenn sich das so öfter
mal läuft sag ich mal
und zwar so roger waters ohne malus aber
richtig darauf wert legen mit wem man
jetzt schreibt oder vor allem das
mädchen mit welchen mädchen man jetzt
schreibt mit welchen man was schreib und
dann ist es so bei mir gewesen manchmal
oder so
generell ist das so man löst so den
einen oder anderen verlaufen dann die
eine oder andere nachricht wisst ihr das
halt so damit kein streit entsteht und
eigentlich braucht man das gar nicht
aber immer noch zeit automatisch weil
weil man das was ich will ich will jetzt
nicht sagen dass ich immer so den chat
fall auf gelöschte oder so aber so ab
und zu ganz selten wenn man sich denkt
ja das muss sie jetzt nicht unbedingt
lesen auch wenn man sich eigentlich
nichts schlimmes dabei gedacht er dann
löscht man das schon mal
ich werde dir kennen das alle oder viele
von euch und somit kommen wir auch schon
zum nächsten punkt wenn du beim feiern
oder irgendwo dein handy nicht dabei
hast das ist einfach nur ein todesurteil
dein freund will ich einfach rund um die
uhr erreichen können bzw kontrollanrufe
machen können und wenn sie das nicht
kann mein freund dann sieht es ganz
schön schlecht für dich aus also schau
dass dein handy immer ladung hat und du
es immer an deiner hosentasche hast dann
wird ihr auch nichts passieren und wie
es glücklich mit deiner freundin alt so
lange du ein handy ab so leute was auch
noch extrem nervös und ich wette das
kind auch fast alle von euch fernsehen
gucken also dass das ding ist dabei wenn
man halt zwischen zwei programmen
entscheiden muss stellt euch vor einmal
fußball und auf dem anderen programm
germany's next topmodel oder irgendwie
sowas also einen frauen kram und man
streitet sich dann halt immer darum was
man jetzt gucken will und das trägt
überlaufen mit der zeit einfach wenn ich
halt nicht das gucken will was ich will
wenn es blöd ich denke mal das ist bei
jedem so ja leute so viel dazu ich würde
sagen in der beschreibung kommt ihr zum
anderen teil der als bei morys auf dem
kanal sein kann als auch in der video
beschreibung alles schön verlinkt und
hier ist nochmal instagram eingebildeter
geil wenn ihr folgen würde
und dann würde ich sagen aber nicht
vergessen um nichts mehr zu verpassen
hier auf der linken seite geht es weiter
mit dem video was halt noch wir auf
seinem kart gedreht haben und hier auf
der anderen seite mit meinem es mit
meinem letzten video das war vorteile
jeder frau auch auf jeden fall mehr
abdecken und dann sehen wir uns auch
schon am wochenende wieder hotline unter
tel